welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity you know the party of Tolerance
has once again shown nothing but hate
this time attacking new 2024
presidential candidate Nikki Haley take
a watch
you're not a new generation you're 51
what are you talking about
the DC though compared to DC that's a
new generation but it's not a new
generation she may be she may be younger
than most of those people but her
rhetoric is the same she's saying the
same BSN so I see her and I feel sad
many because she uses her brown skin as
a weapon against poor black folks and
poor Brown folks and she uses her brown
skin to launder white supremacist
talking points Nikki Haley is in a prime
sorry when a woman is considered being a
prime in her 20s and 30s and maybe 40s
she uses her brown skin as a weapon
that's what they say openly while
mocking her age on The View
Don Lemon by the way faced widespread
backlash for those disgusting comments
as he was seen frolicking on the beach
in Miami he probably planted that
photographer look at that photo on the
left you think that was accidental hey
just get up a little higher make me look
make me look good on the beach as I jog
and according to One Network Insider at
CNN Don lemon's return to the show
depends on quote where his head is at
which is what we all ask when we watch
him by the way he was not on the show
this morning joining us now with her
reaction 2024 presidential candidate
former governor and U.N Ambassador Nikki
Haley uh Ambassador thank you so much
for being here just your response to the
to the way in which the media has come
after you
you know I'm not surprised Pete I mean I
have dealt with this all my life they
can't stand a conservative minority
female not being a Democrat and so they
will continue to throw everything when I
first won the governorship in South
Carolina it was liberal minority
Democrats that said she's not a minority
she's just a conservative with a tan I
mean this is going to continue to happen
but it infuriates them because they know
we win independence they know we win
Suburban women they know that we win
minorities because our Solutions lift up
everyone not just a select few but more
importantly look at how hypocritical
this is if a republican had said this
about Kamala Harris if a republican had
said this about any Democrat they'd be
asking for people to be fired you're not
hearing any of that I mean first day it
was Whoopi Goldberg the second day it's
Don Lemon you know today the view picks
it back up again and they're trying to
glorify Dianne Feinstein and you know
man vaccine Waters when I say we should
have mental competency tests for people
over the age of 75. you know we've we've
easily struck a nerve but I'll wear it
as a badge of honor
did you anticipate this generational
thing I mean 51 I'd like to think is
very young especially when you look at
Washington DC I'll be 51 before I blink
this is you're you're you are you know
well in the the in the middle of a
political career you've done so many
things already so much ahead and you've
got a Democrat Party that has been
lauding Nancy Pelosi for decades who's
just a tad bit uh older you're senior
than you did you think age would be the
issue that they would latch on we knew
race they're so silly about that but age
it's all they had I mean they were just
looking for something I mean I am 30
years younger than Joe Biden they
seriously had looked at if you look at
polls Democrats don't even want him you
can't say I'm old when you've got a
president that's 31 32 years older than
me I mean that's ridiculous but at the
end of the day we're going to talk about
things that matter I am at Royal
flooring here in Urbandale Iowa and what
they care about is they want
accountability in D.C they do want a
Washington Outsider they want term
limits they want mental competency tests
for elected officials they want
government to remember they work for the
people not the other way around and so
the lips can get upset all they want I
saw Bernie Sanders lost his mind over it
but you know when they get defensive
about it who do they think they are that
the people in America don't deserve to
see what the mental competency of these
elected officials are why are they so
upset that we're asking for term limits
why are they so upset that we want them
to balance a budget I think it just goes
to show Washington needs to be cleaned
up a lot more than we thought
well it sure does uh and you know what's
more important the ideas you hold or
your age because there's there was some
criticism of unconservative circles you
know this that I that an allusion to a
generational change is an allusion to
the current front runner Donald Trump so
is this is this really about ideas or is
it about age what's what's most
important to you
look I think it's about transparency uh
like Americans need to know that their
elected officials are capable of making
the really tough decisions these are
decisions on National Security these are
decisions on what happens with our debt
these are decisions on their children's
education
Americans deserve to know these things
and we need to have transparency and so
this isn't saying that you can't do your
job this is saying that you need to be
transparent enough that you tell the
American people whether you're at the
top of your game and I don't see
anything wrong with that this isn't
about one person this isn't about
presidential candidates I want this for
congress I want this for all members of
Congress to be able to do that look at
D.C right now look at how old it is are
you comfortable that they can deal with
a Chinese spy balloon are you
comfortable that they can deal if North
Korea is testing ballistic missiles are
you comfortable if Iran's trying to get
the bomb no we need to know that we've
got people in Washington who are capable
of making these decisions and more
importantly that they remember who it is
that they work for and they've lost that
and everybody that's getting defensive
about this says more about them than it
does about the fact that we're trying to
change this
and that they remember you know what day
of the week it is it's a very important
thing uh if you're in a leadership role
uh real quick big story
in Ukraine hasn't been to East Palestine
how would you approach this issue at
this moment
it's very telling that here you have one
of the worst crises that we have is on
our border and Joe Biden won't come now
you've got these poor Americans sitting
in Ohio the first thing I did this as
Governor we had hurricanes we had floods
we had a church shooting we had a school
shooting the first thing you do is go be
with your people the very first thing
and you take your agencies with you Joe
Biden should have shown up Kamala Harris
should have shown up and all of their
agency heads should have shown up we had
a train derailment in South Carolina let
me tell you something those chemicals
they go into the ground they go into the
water they are in the air you have to
tell all of the people of the affected
area what you know what you believe is
going to happen and how you can earn
their trust in being back there this is
about parents raising their kids there
this is about people being comfortable
breathing the air it's unacceptable that
a president would not go for something
like this it when it's that serious this
is a crisis and he always runs from a
crisis
once again it comes back to transparency
well Ambassador Nikki Haley thank you so
much for your time tonight we appreciate
it hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else